In this problem, a town is building a
cylindrical water stand pipe to help
maintain pressure in its distribution
system. They want to make sure the
farthest customer sees a minimum
pressure of 25 PSI and a maximum of 45
PSI. Due to friction, there is 7 PSI of
pressure loss in the system. If this
water tower is 8 ft in diameter, what is
the minimum required water level in the
tank? And what is the usable volume of
water stored between the maximum and
minimum pressure levels?
So this problem is asking us to find the
max height, min height, and volume
available between those point in the
stand pipe.
So the first thing we can do here is
convert our provided pressures into
equivalent heights.
If we search PSI in the reference
manual, section 1.2 under conversion
factors will give us the conversion of 1
PSI equals 2.307
ft.
[Music]
So step one is going to be converting
our pressures to heights.
To maintain 25 PSI at the farthest
customer, we have to account not only
for this minimum pressure, but also for
the 7 PSI of friction loss that needs to
be overcome as well.
So the tank will need to supply a
pressure of 25 + 7 or 32 PSI.
From there, we can multiply by our
conversion factor found in the reference
manual of 2.307
ft per psi.
Summing and multiplying these together
gives us 73.8 ft.
Next, we can find the maximum
height in the stand pipe.
So similarly, we're going to take the
maximum PSI of 45 and add our 7 PSI of
pressure loss and multiply again by our
conversion from PSI to feet.
[Music]
And that's going to give us just about
120 ft for the maximum height in the
tank.
So what we're seeing here is that the
tank can vary between 73.8 and 120 ft
while still meeting the required
pressure requirements for this problem.
It is within that range that the total
volume of water that is usable would
exist. So we can use the difference in
heights here to find the total volume of
usable water which is the second part of
the problem.
Looking at our answers, we can also
recognize that we can already eliminate
two of them since they don't match the
correct minimum tank height. So, just to
draw this stand pipe out very quickly,
we can see that there's going to be a
maximum usable height in the tank and a
minimum height in the tank. And the rest
of this is going to be distributed
throughout the system.
And since the tank is cylindrical
because it's a stand pipe, we can see
that the diameter is going to be 8 ft
all the way through. So again, knowing
the max height and the min height in the
tank gives us our total height of water
that we can use.
From there, we can use the equation of a
cylinder
to calculate this volume.
And that's going to be p<unk> d ^ 2 / 4
* h.
Substituting in with real terms, we
get<unk>
* 8 ft^ 2 / 4
* our height of 46.2 ft.
And this will calculate out to about
2,321
cubic feet of water in the stand pipe
within the usable range.
Finally, all we have to do is convert
this cubic feet of water into gallons
using our conversion factor of 7.48 gall
per cubic foot.
And our final answer would be 17,361
gall, which is very close to our fourth
answer at the bottom here.
[Music]
So this problem is very straightforward
and the only three things you have to
look up or know automatically are the
conversions for PSI to feet,
gallons to cubic feet, and the equation
of a cylinder. And that's it.